they
epsilon T State Hospital summer of 1959
I left teaching to begin an ambitious
study of delusional patients I would
really like to help you Joseph he's
addressed me as my proper name Jesus
Christ the righteous one am I
they have three patients who believe
they're Jesus Christ there can be but
only one side of that that's my point
dress me by my righteous name God to you
don't put the three of them in Rome
study their behavior what do you think
will happen
the reason I'm having these meetings
that can only be one Jesus only one God
one God to realize hex I'm taking off
all of your negativity and all of your
squelches all of your squelching we do
not have forth follow that God's in
Great Britain there are fathers send a
boy to do a man's job
knock it off knock your Ellen please be
careful is it possible to really
understand someone else's delusion there
are limits
you can't exceed
it's brave and important what you're
doing you decide if the gains outweigh
the obvious risks
gentlemen I want one of you to lead each
of the meetings I think we should have a
vote I nominate Joseph Daul family
[Music]
unanimous why do you want to work with
paranoid schizophrenics
because is so lonely
by the grace of Jesus Christ you're safe
companionship joy hope
oh I be able to offer these men a means
to find themselves
you